[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans la lumière d'un pari de printemps
s'est déroulée la cérémonie anniversaire
de la victoire de 1945 le général de
Gaulle a remonté les Champs-Élysées pour
aller s'incliner sur l'atome du soldat
inconnu minute de recueillement et de
souvenirs
[Musique]
quelques heures plus tôt à Orléans le
Premier ministre célébrait le 534ème
anniversaire d'une autre libération en
1429 Jeanne d'Arc hier simple bergère
signait par la libération d'Orléans le
premier acte majeur de sa grandiose
histoire Orléans n'a jamais cessé depuis
de commémorer cette journée quel
français par ailleurs ne garde dans son
cœur une place pour cet enfant de
Domrémy dont la maison est restée
intacte
à ce foyer elle médite assez sombre
elle a connu le jour de cette fenêtre
étroite et cette armoire a renfermé ses
habits
mais le pays entier parle de Jeanne
de la prairie où elle jouait avec ses
compagnes jusqu'à la fontaine des
fièvreux combragait peut-être à cette
époque le fameux arbre des fées près
duquel elle écouta ses voix
[Musique]
elle dit adieu à tout cela un jour à
l'appel de sa mission
à vos couleurs se trouve toujours la
chapelle où Jeanne attendit toute une
nuit la permission du cire de
Baudricourt d'aller rachido
et c'est par cette porte de France
quelle partie pour accomplir ce destin
merveilleux et tragique qui devait la
conduire à Orléans et à Reims pour finir
sur le bûcher de Rouen
[Musique]
le Festival de Cannes qui transforme
chaque année pour trois semaines la vie
des Cannois a pris le départ avec la
Bégum une habituée quelques vedettes
japonaises des passantes et Robert
Hossein ce sont 2000 invités venues de
30 pays star starlette réalisateur
producteurs qui vont voir défiler
quelques 200 films c'est à dire quelques
400 km de pellicules
c'est Hitchcock qui a ouvert le feu avec
sa vedette tipi et de Rennes et son film
les oiseaux
et voici comment les oiseaux se vendent
[Musique]
à Saclay Monsieur Francis Perrin a
visité une exposition dont les vedettes
étaient les robots de l'âge atomique
ses bras de métal au pince menaçante que
l'homme s'est inventé pour travailler à
l'abri des radiations pour les
techniciens il s'agit très prosaïquement
de télé manipulateurs
[Musique]
pour Ali la puissance à la précision ce
qui n'exclut pas la plus grande
délicatesse et tel d'un truc qui peut
soulever 300 kg peut aussi bien saisir
un œuf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ingénieurs atomistes disposent même
aujourd'hui d'une véritable main de
rechange ce qui tendrait à prouver que
la main est le plus parfait des robots
[Musique]
une nouvelle crise secoue le sud des
États-Unis à Birmingham en Alabama des
manifestations de la population noire en
faveur de l'égalité raciale ont dégénéré
en hurt violent au cours desquels la
police a procédé à plus de 2000
arrestations il y a eu également des
blessés par disait
[Musique]
la police a fait appel au lance des
pompiers dont le GET est assez puissant
pour briser la membre comme au chien
policier triste renouveau d'un problème
dramatique dont le président Kennedy a
au dernier nouvel décidé de se mêler
malgré l'opposition du gouverneur de
l'Alabama
[Musique]
les visages charmants qui sont ceux de
l'enfance ne sauraient plus aujourd'hui
faire illusion depuis que ce sont
développés les techniques de la
psychanalyse fondée sur les théories de
Sigmund Freud les psychologues sont
habiles à découvrir au détour d'un
dessin le contenu complexe d'une lame
infantile révolte contre l'école et
l'autorité paternelle par exemple
révélée par l'inversion volontaire des
lettres
[Musique]
l'origine de bien des comportements
étranges apparaît ainsi en clair
inquiétude d'aller de l'avant
sensation d'être abandonné
crainte inconsciente d'une hypothétique
menace
[Musique]
quant au sentiment d'agressivité il
s'exprime à travers tout un monde peuplé
d'armes à feu
que les parents se consolent donc ils ne
sont plus sans ressource même en face
des cas les plus désespérés même en face
de ce garnement en apparence le plus
affreux qu'on puisse imaginer
[Musique]
celui-ci qui ne respectent rien que ses
camarades craignent Et que ces maîtres
finissent eux aussi par redouter et pour
cause
[Musique]
véritable démon terreur de la classe
abonnés au panoplie de cowboy c'est
évidemment le jeune fauve type que des
parents trop faibles ont renoncé à
dompter
celui dont le carnet de notes
particulièrement éloquant clair est une
atmosphère de deuil illimité et s'il
n'avait depuis longtemps sur un verset
la situation en y glissant par exemple
en prévision de la fête des mères un
billet de la Loterie Nationale
innocence bien sûr le brave petit
que les amis des pigeons pour qu'il ait
Bizet et autres palombes sont un des
charmes de Paris en même temps que le
symbole et les de l'amour fidèle se
rassure la dépigénisation n'est pas
l'extermination seulement devant
l'accumulation de méfaits caractériser
et l'affichage d'un sans-gêne qui
confine parfois au crime de l’aise
majesté il fallait bien agir la bonne
tenue des monuments publics leur
réclamait l'intérêt de la propriété
privée l'exigeait disons qu'à l'heure où
Paris avait entrepris sa grande
opération de ravalement pour retrouver
sa blancheur originelle le souci des
édiles rejoignait celui de certains
particuliers en lutte ouverte avec les
pigeons restaient la manière pas
question évidemment de barder les
bâtiments d'épouvantail et hétéroclite
[Musique]
la destruction systématique des œufs
les pigeons font 9 couvés par an
quand à l'intervention violente les
pauvres ne méritent pas cela
alors des équipes ont été chargés de
parcourir Paris à l'heure des repas pour
les capturer au filet en douceur
[Musique]
que les amis des bêtes soient totalement
tranquillisées ces captures ne préluent
nullement à de sanguinaires hécatonges
elles n'ont pour but que d'éloigner le
pari 40 000 pigeons sur les 80000 qui
vivent aujourd'hui ce qui est vraiment
trop
on ne pouvait naître plus de forme
règlement de ce problème même en cage
ils sont traités avec les plus grands
égards
puis ils sont conduits par compagnie
entière chaque fin de semaine vers un
coin de campagne
[Musique]
là c'est pigeons qui selon les
spécialistes ont toujours joui d'un
tempérament casanier se fixeront et
pourront en somme refaire leur vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]